Shure:  你给的是那个靖蝎啊
Shure: You gave him the quiet scorpion.
Shure:  你被这种人
Shure: You got beaten by this kind of person.
Nicous: 已经红了
Nicous: He's already red.
Tasha: 哈哈他他打不过我
Tasha: Haha, he can't beat me.
Tasha: 然后他还可以再跟我玩
Tasha: And then he can still play with me.
Katrina:  你那里有几片啊Lucy
Katrina: How many pieces do you have there, Lucia?
Lucia: 嗯我下下面那个是4片
Lucia: Hmm, the one below is 4 pieces.
Lucia: 不过是小的
Lucia: But they are small.
Tasha: 卖谁啊
Tasha: Sell to whom?
Jake: 怎么还
Jake: Why still...
Tasha: 卖谁啊
Tasha: Sell to whom?
Jake: 还你是挂了吗
Jake: Are you hanging up?
Nicous: 我投了
Nicous: I surrendered.
Jake: 投了
Jake: Surrendered.
Jake: 现在就剩他和人机打的
Jake: Now it's just him playing with the bot.
Nicous: 那个是人
Nicous: That's a person.
Jake:哦一个真人咯
Jake: Oh, a real person.
Nicous: 至少把我打赢肯定不是人机
Nicous: At least he beat me, definitely not a bot.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  雇佣劳动力
Katrina: Hired labor.
Jake: 赢了吗
Jake: Did you win?
Tasha: 在谢冰竹的英明指导下
Tasha: Under Bingzhu Xie's wise guidance...
Tasha: 我输掉了
Tasha: I lost.
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why?
Shure:  跟杨老板申请申请
Shure: Apply to Jake.
Tasha: 他指导我把人全卖了追人
Tasha: He guided me to sell everyone and chase people.
Jake: 你怎么会
Jake: How could you...
Katrina:  你是人啊
Katrina: Are you human?
Jake: 哦  你怎么会输呢
Jake: Oh, how could you lose?
Tasha: 你为什么在楼上
Tasha: Why are you upstairs?
Jake: 因为我在看这个电池
Jake: Because I'm checking this battery.
Shure:  借了个纸你去做狗
Shure: Borrowed a paper, then you play the dog.
Jake: 你知道这个电池是5号的
Jake: You know this battery is AA.
Jake: 还是7号的吗
Jake: Or AAA?
Tasha: 我肯定可以知道
Tasha: I can definitely tell.
Tasha: 5号
Tasha: AA.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake:谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Tasha: 今天下午干嘛玩啊
Jake: 要不
Jake: How about...
Jake: 做狗他们在做狗吗
Jake: Playing the dog, are they playing the dog?
Jake: 什么老师
Jake: What teacher?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  他叫我轩老师
Katrina: He calls me Teacher Xuan.
Katrina:  他是那种上补习班的小孩
Katrina: He's the kind of kid who goes to tutoring.
Katrina:  然后我是旁边老师
Katrina: And I'm the nearby teacher.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure:  你直接坐一下不就得了
Shure: You just sit for a bit, it'll be fine.
Lucia: 不行你要把这袋子拉紧
Lucia: No, you need to pull this bag tight.
Lucia: 哦你这意思我坐在上面拉
Lucia: Oh, you mean I should sit on it and pull?
Shure:  对什么叫坐在上面拉
Shure: Yeah, what do you mean sit on it and pull?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  好奇怪
Katrina: So weird.
Lucia: 这句话能删掉吗
Lucia: Can we delete this line?
Jake: 翻译过去
Jake: Translate it.
Jake: 一没有一点问题
Jake: There's no problem at all.
Jake: 没有一点问题
Jake: No problem at all.
Jake:呵
Jake: Heh.
Shure:  你在拉里拉萨
Shure: You're pulling in Lhasa.
Jake: 什么怎怎么翻译这个
Jake: What, how do you translate this?
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Jake: 什么叫坐
Jake: What do you mean sit?
Jake: 什么叫做
Jake: What do you mean do?
Lucia: 我的一世英名啊
Lucia: My reputation!
Shure:  sit sit谁
Shure: Sit, sit, who?
Jake: 谁谁坐
Jake: Who, who sits?
Shure:  他他我我
Shure: Him, him, me, me.
Lucia: 就这个我刚才想把它拉紧然后
Lucia: Just this, I tried to tighten it just now and...
Shure:  这不压了这个花吗
Shure: Won't this crush the flower?
Katrina:  修硕说我可以
Katrina: Shure said I could.
Jake: 为什么要坐
Jake: Why sit?
Lucia: 就是坐在上面这样可以压得更紧
Lucia: Sitting on it will press it tighter.
Jake: 你你你sitting on
Jake: You, you, you sitting on...
Jake: 你sitting on the board是吧
Jake: You sitting on the board, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia:然后我说不行就这个东西要拉紧
Lucia: And then I said, no, this thing needs to be tightened.
Jake: 哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Jake: P Puling with you sitting on it right啊OK
Jake: Pulling with you sitting on it, right? Ah, okay.
Shure:  啊你先铺铺点
Shure: Ah, you lay it out first.
Jake: 怎么
Jake: What?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我靠哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my god, hahaha.
Shure:  你这这中文是互通的有没有
Shure: Is your Chinese even understandable?
Jake: 有有有有
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  你不做完一遍了吗
Shure: Didn't you do it once already?
Shure:  你怎么还需要学啊
Shure: Why do you still need to learn?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 什么时候做狗
Jake: When do we make the dog?
Nicous: 我感觉如果你刚才
Nicous: I feel if you just now...
Lucia: 做狗谁不会啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Who can't make a dog? Hahaha.
Nicous: 换成Mac Pro Apple加速特别牛
Nicous: Replace it with a Mac Pro, Apple's acceleration is amazing.
Jake: 把什么
Jake: What?
Nicous: 换成Mac Pro Apple
Nicous: Replace it with a Mac Pro, Apple.
Jake: 我我有
Jake: I, I have one.
Jake: 那试试
Jake: Then let's try it.
Nicous: 等这波结束
Nicous: After this round.
Nicous: 下一波试
Nicous: Try it next round.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:哪有现在
Jake: How about now?
Jake:什么4点的什么
Jake: What's the 4 o'clock thing?
Jake:现在有四点零的
Jake: Is there a 4 o'clock now?
Jake:ok
Jake: Okay.
Jake:试试 试试
Jake: Try it, try it.
Lucia:我先简单的尝试一下
Lucia: Let me give it a simple try first.
Shure: oh
Shure: Oh
Shure: do do do do do do steal
Lucia:这两边不一样紧哎
Lucia: These two sides aren't equally tight.
Katrina: 没事然后搞个密封袋把它密封住
Katrina: It's okay, just get a sealed bag to seal it.
Shure: 你看看是不是还得坐上
Shure: Check if you need to sit on it.
Lucia:我这叫从善如流
Lucia: I call this going with the flow.
Jake:在来一份
Jake: Another serving, please.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:小手法
Jake: A small technique.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Jake:什么梗啊这是
Jake: What's the joke here?
Jake:什么梗啊什么梗啊
Jake: What's the joke? What's the joke?
Jake:说来听听
Jake: Tell me about it.
Shure: 就可以大家都听不懂的状态下
Shure: It's about targeting him precisely when no one else understands.
Shure: 然后精准的攻击到他
Shure: Then attacking him accurately.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:可以
Jake: That's good.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:我没去过
Jake: I haven't been there.
Katrina: 克星
Katrina: Nemesis.
Jake:走带我们去吧
Jake: Let's go, take us there.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:走上楼再抓一个人
Jake: Let's go upstairs and grab another person.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Jake:三楼还有一个薇薇
Jake: There's another Tasha on the third floor.
Jake:走做狗去
Jake: Let's go see the dog.
Jake:看看狗去
Jake: Let's go look at the dog.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where is everyone?
Jake:where are you
Jake: Where are you?
Jake:没有没有薇薇
Jake: No, no Tasha.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:嚯哦
Jake: Whoa oh.
Lucia:哎你的地毯已经到了
Lucia: Hey, your rug has arrived.
Jake:是条狗
Jake: It's a dog.
Lucia:我目前到的材料还没有一个是蓝色的
Lucia: None of the materials I've got so far are blue.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:然后我让我许愿我的计划能顺利进行
Lucia: So, I wish my plan goes smoothly.
Lucia:这个剪刀有点不好使
Lucia: These scissors are a bit dull.
Jake:你
Jake: You...
Jake:你要不买点颜料
Jake: Why don't you buy some paint?
Jake:也可以看看有什么颜色
Jake: You can also see what colors there are.
Jake:你现在是什么颜色
Jake: What color are you now?
Lucia:我现在都是白色的
Lucia: I'm all white now.
Jake:白色
Jake: White.
Lucia:但我觉得它
Lucia: But I think it...
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:至少那个鱼网
Lucia: At least that fishnet...
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Tasha:哦要出门了是吧
Tasha: Oh, are we heading out?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:白色
Jake: White.
Jake:我们要看狗了
Jake: We're going to see the dog.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha:为什么我们一群人要看一只狗
Tasha: Why are we all going to see a dog?
Tasha:就感觉他是一个
Tasha: It feels like he's...
Tasha:孤独的需要被看望的
Tasha: Lonely and needs to be visited.
Jake:因为我们要做狗
Jake: Because we need to be dogs.
Tasha:空巢老人一样
Tasha: Like an empty-nester.
Lucia:建立一些逻辑联系
Lucia: Build some logical connections.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia:因为我们可能要做狗
Lucia: Because we might need to be dogs.
Jake:是对 我们
Jake: Yes, we...
Jake:是我们要做狗
Jake: Yes, we need to be dogs.
Jake:我们要学习怎么做狗
Jake: We need to learn how to be dogs.
Jake:我们要跟狗请教一下怎么做狗
Jake: We need to ask the dog how to be a dog.
Tasha:那我要做一只可爱小狗
Tasha: Then I want to be a cute puppy.
Jake:小狗 好嘞
Jake: Puppy, got it.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:所以昨天为什么要抢红包
Tasha: So why did we grab red envelopes yesterday?
Tasha:明明这是用
Tasha: Clearly, it's about speed.
Tasha:手速得来
Tasha: Quick hands.
Jake:因为他没有钱是吧
Jake: Because he doesn't have money, right?
Tasha:没有钱大家还是一样的
Tasha: No money, everyone's the same.
Jake:那提前拿到钱嘛多好
Jake: Isn't it great to get money early?
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Jake:一脸蒙逼
Jake: So confused.
Jake:你猜
Jake: Take a guess.
Nicous: 我猜啊
Nicous: I'll guess.
Jake:你们很懂吗
Jake: Do you really understand?
Jake: Do you guys really understand?
Shure: 非常懂
Shure: Totally understand.
Jake:非常懂
Jake: Totally understand.
Jake:那那那猜一下
Jake: Then, then, take a guess.
Jake:哪里懂得什么
Jake: What exactly do you understand?
Katrina: 就是知道了你座以后才能大概猜一下你性格
Katrina: Well, once we know your seat, we can guess your personality.
Jake:不能反推是吧对
Jake: Can't you reverse it? Right.
Jake:guitar可能没放这些东西
Jake: Maybe the guitar didn't have those things.
Shure: 那上那上另一个HAP上找找去哈哈哈
Shure: Then go find it on another HAP, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:天秤秤
Jake: Libra.
Jake:十月份
Jake: October.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 风像的
Katrina: Air sign.
Shure: 他是风相
Shure: He's an air sign.
Katrina: 他不像
Katrina: He doesn't seem like one.
Shure: 不对啊
Shure: No way.
Jake:风相应该是什么样
Jake: What should an air sign be like?
Shure: 风相就是
Shure: An air sign is...
Nicous: 向往
Nicous: Aspirational.
Shure: 对就是每天都是
Shure: Yeah, like, every day...
Shure: 还想和你谈论宇宙和天空
Shure: Wants to talk about the universe and the sky with you.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 或是沙滩里的碎石和人生
Shure: Or the pebbles on the beach and life.
Shure: 哦就是这个样子的一个人
Shure: That's the kind of person.
Katrina: 这老师可不温柔
Katrina: This teacher is not gentle at all.
Katrina: 但是我妈让我学师范
Katrina: But my mom wants me to study teaching.
Katrina: 我说你觉得我能学师范
Katrina: I said, do you think I can study teaching?
Katrina: 我打小孩
Katrina: I hit kids.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 棍棒底下出孝子
Shure: Spare the rod, spoil the child.
Shure: 严师出高徒
Shure: Strict teachers produce outstanding students.
Shure: 这个话不无道理
Shure: There's some truth in that.
Shure: 你给他拆了
Shure: Did you take it apart?
Katrina: 不小心掉出一片
Katrina: A piece accidentally fell off.
Shure: 我就想让他整一个这样子
Shure: I just wanted him to make one like this.
Katrina: 整一个这个压不了啊
Katrina: Making one like this won't work.
Katrina: 除非你一天到晚用屁股坐着他才能压
Katrina: Unless you sit on it all day, it won't press down.
Shure: 可以
Shure: It can work.
Katrina: 蛮敬业的哟
Katrina: Very dedicated.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Lucia:只要接触空调就会缩水
Lucia: As long as it touches the air conditioner, it will shrink.
Lucia: 那应该不至于
Lucia: That shouldn't be the case.
Lucia:这个是雨轩的吗
Lucia: Is this Rain Xuan's?
Lucia:是那种蜡烛式的吗
Lucia: Is it one of those candle types?
Lucia:好好看等你拆了记得叫我观摩一下
Lucia: Looks nice. When you open it, remember to let me watch.
Lucia:其实我今天打开了这个盒子
Lucia: Actually, I opened this box today.
Lucia:发现里面还有一层盒子
Lucia: Found another layer inside.
Lucia:你没有拆过
Lucia: You haven't opened it?
Lucia:我就决定先留着让你拆
Lucia: I decided to leave it for you to open.
Katrina: 我也不知道长啥样呢
Katrina: I don't know what it looks like either.
Katrina: 万一跟那个色吸食物
Katrina: What if it's like that color...
Jake:走看狗去
Jake: Let's go see the dog.
Jake:可以了吧
Jake: Is it okay now?
Nicous: go
Nicous: Go.
Jake:狗 狗 狗 狗
Jake: Dog, dog, dog, dog.
Jake:快去
Jake: Hurry up.
Jake:还有还有人呢
Jake: There's still someone else.
Jake:柯欣呢
Jake: Where's Ke Xin?
Lucia:这是一个自由选择的副本
Lucia: This is a free choice mission.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:对就是遛弯
Jake: It's just a walk.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:那个能孵出什么花
Jake: What kind of flower can hatch from that?
Lucia:这压花的意思其实是压在花上是吧
Lucia: The meaning of pressing flowers is actually to press them onto flowers, right?
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:走走走
Jake: Go, go, go.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Tasha:盐
Tasha: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Jake:盐什么
Jake: Salt what?
Tasha:盐
Tasha: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Lucia:盐
Lucia: Salt.
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Tasha:盐
Tasha: Salt.
Jake:没盐了
Tasha:不可能呀
Tasha: No way.
Jake:我能这么能吃
Jake: I can eat that much.
Lucia:没桃了还有可能没盐应该不至于吧
Lucia: It's possible to run out of peaches, but salt? That shouldn't happen.
Jake:能在哪呢
Jake: Where could it be?
Tasha:不知道
Tasha: No idea.
Jake:应该都在这吧
Jake: It should all be here.
Tasha:可恶
Tasha: Darn it.
Jake:对买勺了
Jake: Right, I bought a spoon.
Jake:盐没盐了怎么办
Jake: What should we do without salt?
Jake:盐
Jake: Salt.
Jake:盐在这
Jake: The salt is here.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake:但是我们先去看狗吧
Jake: But let's go see the dog first.
Tasha:看狗半个小时
Tasha: Watching the dog for half an hour.
Jake:好半小时绰绰有余
Jake: Half an hour is more than enough.
Tasha:10分钟
Tasha: 10 minutes.
Jake:多久啊一般
Jake: How long usually?
Jake:狗能看个10分钟吗
Jake: Can we watch the dog for 10 minutes?
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:走吧出发
Jake: Let's go, let's head out.
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Ouch.
Jake:走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:没有就是躲雨
Jake: If not, just wait out the rain.
Jake:哎今天天适合出去玩做什么
Jake: Hey, today is good for going out, doing something.
Jake:哎呦这个单手开不了
Jake: Ah, can't open this with one hand.
Jake:露亚不去吗
Jake: Lucia's not going?
Jake:没人了
Jake: No one else is here.
Jake:在哪
Jake: Where?
Jake:走 带路 皇军得带路
Jake: Let's go, lead the way. The army needs to lead.
Jake:怎么啦
Jake: What's wrong?
Jake:不用扣上
Jake: No need to buckle up.
Jake:没关系的我
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:呵呵呵呵答晚了
Jake: Haha, answered late.
Jake:赛博小队
Jake: Cyber squad.
Jake:慧欣你带充电器了没
Jake: Huixin, did you bring the charger?
Jake:好的强 牛逼
Jake: Great, awesome.
Jake:你有吗
Jake: Do you have it?
Jake:你没有
Jake: You don't have it.
Lucia:我当然有了
Lucia: Of course I do.
Jake:强
Jake: Strong.
Jake:哎 猫
Jake: Hey, cat.
Jake:葱 韭菜
Jake: Green onions, chives.
Jake:想割
Jake: Want to cut.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe.
Jake:这是韭菜吗
Jake: Are these chives?
Jake:不是
Jake: No.
Jake:完了
Jake: Done.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe.
Jake:每个人都有不同的解读
Jake: Everyone has different interpretations.
Lucia:这话五谷不分呢
Lucia: You don't even know the basics.
Jake:好啊
Jake: Alright.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe.
Jake:拔 拔一点可以
Jake: Pull, pull a little bit.
Jake:等等等等等等
Jake: Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Jake:葡萄
Jake: Grapes.
Jake:什么
Jake: What?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:长得跟葡萄似的
Jake: Looks like grapes.
Jake:哈哈哈不太圆
Jake: Haha, not too round.
Lucia:给您准备好了
Lucia: Got it ready for you.
Jake:不太圆这葡萄啊
Jake: These grapes aren't too round.
Jake:一个老朋友
Jake: An old friend.
Jake:are ronder you
Jake: Are ronder you.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:唉
Jake: Sigh.
Jake:哦谢谢你
Jake: Oh, thank you.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake:哎赛博小队
Jake: Hey, Cyber Squad.
Jake:前来观摩
Jake: Here to observe.
Jake:哎他为什么找我
Jake: Hey, why is he looking for me?
其他人：它爱咬这种它喜欢这种托鞋
Small Dog Owner: It loves to chew on these slippers.
Jake:噢吃了吗
Jake: Oh, did it eat?
Lucia:好多人他都闻不过来了
Lucia: There are so many people, it can't sniff them all.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:他有名字吗
Jake: Does it have a name?
小狗家长:卡布
Small Dog Owner: Kabu.
邻居:听说是卡布
Neighbor: I heard it's Cabo.
Jake:卡布
Jake: Cabo.
Jake:这颜色确实
Jake: This color is really...
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:啊给抹小肚子了
Alice: Ah, wiped it on the little belly.
Jake:太善良了
Jake: Too kind.
邻居:小屋子养的猫
Neighbor: The cat raised in the small house.
邻居:然后冬天看猫冻死了
Neighbor: Then in winter, saw the cat freeze to death.
邻居:都在家里都是11只
Neighbor: There were 11 of them in the house.
其他人：你放了没有
Puppy Boss: Did you let it out?
邻居:你忘了没有
Neighbor: Did you forget?
邻居:还没忘啊
Neighbor: Haven't forgotten, huh?
Jake:猫
Jake: Cat.
Jake:还有猫是吧
Jake: Still have a cat, right?
Alice:啊小狗味
Alice: Ah, smells like puppy.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: Hahaha, that's brilliant.
其他人:它咬你你走开还小
Puppy Boss: If it bites you, just move away, it's still young.
其他人:长牙长牙
Puppy Boss: Growing teeth, growing teeth.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人:它老想啃东西
Puppy Boss: It always wants to chew on things.
其他人：它才洗了两三天澡就搁这打滚成这样了
Puppy Boss: It just had a bath two or three days ago, now it's rolling around like this.
Jake:握手
Jake: Shake hands.
Nicous: 这小狗多久洗一次呀
Nicous: How often does this puppy get a bath?
Jake:呵呵确实爱咬人
Jake: Haha, it really loves to bite.
Jake:确实爱咬人
Jake: Really loves to bite.
Jake:咬你了吧
Jake: Did it bite you?
Lucia:突然舔一口
Lucia: Suddenly licked.
Jake:舔噢
Jake: Lick, huh.
Jake:他为什么尽咬我
Jake: Why does it always bite me?
Lucia:你看起来像磨牙棒
Lucia: You look like a chew toy.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:这 这
Jake: This, this...
Jake:对有很多摄像头
Jake: Yeah, there are a lot of cameras.
Jake:这我们在做研究
Jake: We're doing research.
Jake:啊对 他
Jake: Oh yeah, he...
其他人:哦 科技产品
Puppy Boss: Oh, technology products.
Jake:科技产品
Jake: Technology products.
Jake:就是 我们在这转一圈
Jake: Just, we take a walk around here.
Jake:你们这房子就 重现出来了
Jake: Your house will be recreated.
Jake:就是重现 就是有一个3D模型对
Jake: It will be recreated, like a 3D model, yeah.
其他人:被你们拍摄下来了
Nicous: Got you on camera!
Jake:然后这狗
Jake: And this dog...
Jake:他揉狗
Jake: He's petting the dog.
Jake:如果不动的话也可以把它建出来
Jake: If it doesn't move, we can still make it work.
Jake:但是现在没办法
Jake: But not now.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:这不能咬
Lucia: You can't bite that.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia:线不能咬
Lucia: You can't bite the cord.
Lucia:别的地方你都可以咬
Lucia: You can bite anything else.
Jake: 对线不能咬
Jake: Right, no biting the cord.
Jake:哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Jake:现在我们还差根管
Jake: Now we still need a tube.
Jake:每人插管
Jake: Everyone needs to insert a tube.
Jake:这这还不是产品
Jake: This isn't a product yet.
Jake:这没有量产
Jake: It's not mass-produced.
Jake:还买不着
Jake: You can't buy it yet.
Lucia:实验阶段
Lucia: It's in the experimental stage.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:呃是算学校学校的研究
Jake: Uh, it's part of the school's research.
Jake:学校 对
Jake: School, yeah.
Jake:然后这产品是那个
Jake: And this product is...
Jake:叫什么脸书脸书脸书Face book mate
Jake: What's it called? Facebook, Facebook, Facebook mate.
Jake:就
Jake: Just...
Jake:就是一个8000美元
Jake: It's like $8000.
Jake:我们来至不同的学校
Jake: We come from different schools.
Jake:但是这个实验室是这个南亚理工的
Jake: But this lab is from Nanyang Technological University.
Jake:新加坡 我从新加坡过来的
Jake: Singapore. I came from Singapore.
其他人:我一个大学同学他在去南亚理工读过书然后
Nicous: I have a college mate who studied at Nanyang Technological University.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:哎哟 撒尿了
Alice: Oh no, he peed.
Jake:他还知道跑过去
Jake: He even ran over.
Jake:哦哪个学校
Jake: Oh, which school?
Jake::哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：然后他是在三亚上完学之后
Nicous: Then he went to Sanya after finishing school.
其他人：好像先去的我那个
Nicous: I think he went there first...
其他人：宿舍同学先去的
Nicous: My dorm mate went there first.
其他人：人大读研在去的
Nicous: Then went to Renmin University for postgraduate studies.
其他人：南亚理工读的那个博士
Nicous: The one who got his PhD from South Asia Tech.
Jake:噢 OK OK  校友啊
Jake: Oh OK OK, a fellow alum.
Jake:为什么跑这么远
Jake: Why did he go so far?
Jake:他为啥跑这么远
Jake:不知道
Jake: No idea.
Alice:阿布
Alice: Abu
Jake:我
Jake: I...
Nicous: 旺旺旺
Nicous: Woof woof woof
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:他应该是在哪拿的
Jake: Where did he get it?
Jake:也没地
Jake: Nowhere.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:是他在叫吗
Jake: Is he the one barking?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:狗狗碎碎
Alice: Doggy bits
Jake:哎呀 我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:干嘛呢
Jake: What are you doing?
Tasha: 摇头晃脑的
Tasha: Shaking his head.
Jake:咬指
Jake: Biting fingers.
Jake:他这衣服是干嘛的
Jake: What's with his clothes?
Jake:能被提起来吗
Jake: Can you lift him up?
Jake:就它这个
Jake: Like this?
Jake:哦溜的是吧
Jake: Oh, it's for walking?
Jake:啊溜的
Jake: Ah, for walking.
Jake:我以为哈哈
Jake: I thought haha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:单手拎
Jake: Holding with one hand.
Jake:塑料袋
Jake: Like a plastic bag.
Jake:唉我去 这是边牧吧
Jake: Oh my, is this a Border Collie?
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Alice:你可真会拉
Alice: You really pull a lot.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:哎哟
Jake: Ouch.
Jake:教训教训
Jake: A lesson learned.
Jake:挨教训了
Jake: Got a lesson.
其他人：躲起来了
Nicous: Hiding now.
Jake:挨打了
Jake: Got hit.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:打了吗
Jake: Did he hit?
Lucia:他打疫苗了吧
Lucia: He got vaccinated, right?
Lucia:那他刚在我手上咬了一下
Lucia: He just bit my hand.
其他人:没事没事
Dog Boss: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:居然没烂
Lucia: It didn't even break the skin.
Lucia:没有就是稍微这样刮了一下
Lucia: No, it just scraped a little.
Lucia:我有必要现在去打个疫苗吗
Lucia: Do I need to get a vaccine now?
Lucia:应该没破的时候
Lucia: It shouldn't have broken the skin.
Jake:应该没事没事
Jake: It should be fine, it's fine.
其他人:啊这也没事
Dog Boss: Yeah, it's nothing.
Jake:没事没事
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:啊那就行
Lucia: Ah, that's good then.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
其他人:别让它咬着
Dog Boss: Just don't let it bite you.
其他人:它打是打了我们就是怕
Dog Boss: It has had its shots, we're just worried.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:嚯 这么能咬
Jake: Whoa, it bites so hard.
Jake:我去 直接咬下去了
Jake: Wow, it really bites down.
Jake:好吃吗
Jake: Is it tasty?
其他人:接哥哥去了晚上来接你哈
Dog Boss: Going to pick up brother, will come get you tonight.
其他人:走了 再见 拜拜
Dog Boss: We're leaving. Bye, bye.
Jake:喜欢托鞋
Jake: Likes slippers.
Nicous: 它这个是长牙要换牙那个
Nicous: It's teething, needs to change teeth.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Nicous: 然后它就是所以就是拿牙齿咬
Nicous: So it's using its teeth to bite.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:当手用
Jake: Using them like hands.
Jake:干哈呢他
Jake: What's he doing?
Jake:咬石头
Jake: Biting a rock.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:呃你你你们没有脸
Jake: Uh, you guys don't have faces.
Jake:就是你们会被打码
Jake: You'll be pixelated.
Jake:对 放心
Jake: Yes, don't worry.
Jake:所有的人包括我们也没有脸
Jake: Everyone, including us, will be pixelated.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
其他人:就是打马赛克是吧
Dog Boss: You mean pixelated, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Jake:哎 它还有一个画像
Jake: Hey, it has a portrait too.
Jake:唉 我去
Jake: Oh my.
Jake:有点想提它 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Kind of want to mention it, hahaha.
Jake:是没提起来啊
Jake: It didn't pick up.
其他人:哎哟
Unknown: Oh no
Jake:哎哟我去不给提
Jake: Oh no, it won't pick up.
Jake:回去回去
Jake: Go back, go back.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh my
Alice:过来
Alice: Come here
Alice:过来 咬鞋子
Alice: Come here, biting the shoe.
Alice:给
Alice: Here
Alice:干啥
Alice: What are you doing?
Jake:它刚刚摔着了吗
Jake: Did it just fall?
Jake:嚯 它又找那个啥玩意
Jake: Whoa, it's looking for that thing again.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh no
Jake:把你提起来
Jake: Let me pick you up.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh my
Jake:哎  不行不行不行这个不行 这个不行
Jake: Oh no, no, no, this won't work, this won't work.
Jake:完了 互换攻击了
Jake: Oh no, they're attacking each other now.
Jake:过去吧
Jake: Go over there.
Jake:唉哪去了
Jake: Hey, where did it go?
Jake:咦
Jake: Huh
Jake:想那么逗猫你逗它
Jake: If you want to tease the cat, tease it.
Jake:哎哟
Jake: Oh no
Alice:吓死我啦
Alice: You scared me to death.
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Holy crap
Jake:嗯 是
Jake: Hmm, yes
Nicous: 那个好多好多猫
Nicous: There are so many cats.
Nicous: 然后这个这个程序里面就是流浪的猫
Nicous: And in this program, there are stray cats.
Nicous: 就是看到过先罗
Nicous: I've seen them before.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Nicous: 看见过好多名贵的品种
Nicous: I've seen many precious breeds.
其他人：先罗 布偶
Unknown: Sphynx, Ragdoll
Nicous: 啊对 都有
Nicous: Yeah, they have all of them.
其他人:里面都有各种名犬名猫
Unknown: There are all kinds of famous dogs and cats in there.
Jake:这么有意思 为啥在这
Jake: So interesting, why are they here?
其他人:不知道全跑那屋里
Unknown: I don't know, they all ran to that room.
Jake:跑的
Jake: They ran.
Nicous: 你说收了多少只猫
Nicous: How many cats do you think they have?
Jake:上哪去了
Jake: Where did they go?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
其他人:一个有一个马桶
Unknown: There's a toilet in each one.
其他人:我家有四个还是六个忘了
Nicous: I can't remember if I have four or six at home.
其他人:最多是六个马桶 就是一人一个
Nicous: At most, we have six toilets, one for each person.
其他人:它不在这里面尿 它就去别的地方尿
Nicous: If it doesn't pee here, it'll pee somewhere else.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice:领地
Alice: Territory.
其他人:它的占地意识特别强
Nicous: It has a very strong sense of territory.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
其他人:这只猫啊和我一个马桶 每天尿到哪里都是
Nicous: This cat shares a toilet with me and pees everywhere every day.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:它这是要干你了它这个
Jake: It's trying to dominate you with that posture.
Jake:这个姿势
Jake: That posture.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:我都没在乎呢
Alice: I didn't even care.
Jake:干哈你干哈
Jake: What are you doing, what are you doing?
Jake:走了
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:看地瓜去吧
Jake: Let's go check out the sweet potatoes.
Tasha:这么害怕
Tasha: So scared.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Alice:很乖呀
Alice: Very well-behaved.
Alice:是不是血统比较纯的那种
Alice: Is it a purebred?
Alice:因为它长得很肥很厚实
Alice: Because it looks very plump and sturdy.
Jake:这这怎么看这很容易看吗
Jake: How do you tell? Is it easy to see?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:就看它的爪子
Alice: Just look at its paws.
Jake:哈这么讲究
Jake: Wow, that's so particular.
Alice:它还挺亲人
Alice: It's very affectionate.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Alice:卡面 我们家有一只大秋田
Alice: We have a big Akita at home named Kame.
Alice:长大了就拆家了
Alice: When it grew up, it started tearing the house apart.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:见啥都咬
Jake: It bites everything it sees.
Alice:现在磨牙
Alice: It's teething now.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Alice:她是在磨牙见啥都咬
Alice: It's teething, so it bites everything it sees.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Jake:头垂
Jake: Lower your head.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Alice:这几个月啊
Alice: These few months...
Jake:这也得问 这
Jake: You need to ask about this...
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:哈哈  是比我熟练多了 哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, you're much more skilled than me. Hahaha
其他人:现在叫它是知道在叫它
Puppy Owner: Now when you call it, it knows you're calling it.
其他人:这是还没长大
Puppy Owner: It's still not grown up yet.
Jake:还得上去
Jake: We still need to go up.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Jake:走吧 要不
Jake: Let's go, or...
Tasha:还是金毛粘人
Tasha: Golden Retrievers are still clingy.
Jake:还能去哪里了
Jake: Where else can we go?
Jake:那我们在晃悠晃悠
Jake: Let's just wander around.
Jake:好 再见
Jake: Okay, bye.
Jake:嚯 哎呀 哎呀 没事
Jake: Wow, ouch, ouch, it's okay.
Jake:啥
Jake: What?
Jake:哦哈
Jake: Oh ha
Jake:还有附近还有啥啊
Jake: What else is nearby?
Nicous: 没了
Nicous: Nothing.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:烤地瓜去吧
Jake: Let's go bake some sweet potatoes.
Jake:哈 烤地瓜
Jake: Haha, baked sweet potatoes.
Jake:他整了点地瓜
Jake: He got some sweet potatoes.
Jake:挖的挖的
Jake: Dug them up.
Alice:现种的
Alice: Freshly planted.
Jake:还是再采采风
Jake: Let's catch the breeze again.
Jake:兜一圈
Jake: Take a lap.
Jake:没什么路可以兜
Jake: There's not much of a path to take.
Jake:就是就是再绕一圈过去
Jake: Just, just take another loop around.
Jake:多走几遍
Jake: Walk a few more times.
Jake:北京是个啥
Jake: What is Beijing?
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈哈啊哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Jake:为为什么有这么高树啊
Jake: Why are there such tall trees?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:给一张照片
Jake: Take a photo.
Jake:北京这里是什么
Jake: What's this place in Beijing?
Jake:然后AI回答是个城市就这个
Jake: And the AI answers it's a city, just this.
Jake:AI就不过审是不是
Jake: The AI wouldn't pass, right?
Jake:AI就是没有过测试
Jake: The AI didn't pass the test.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:打脸
Jake: Embarrassing.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:这个经典QA啊
Jake: This is a classic QA, huh?
Jake:这个是经典VQA是吗
Jake: This is a classic VQA, right?
Lucia:什么给个照片问这是什么
Lucia: What, you give a photo and ask what it is?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:然后对 然后回答的问题
Jake: And then, yeah, then answer the question.
Jake:和图片一点关系都没有了那就是
Jake: And the answer has nothing to do with the picture.
Jake:很标准的哈哈哈
Jake: Very standard, hahaha.
Jake:啊对是的
Jake: Ah, yes.
Jake:我之前就上个月
Jake: Last month...
Jake:和东京大学一帮人做的
Jake: ...I was working with a group from Tokyo University.
Jake:就是做这种
Jake: We were doing this kind of thing.
Lucia:那你们最后成果怎么样了
Lucia: So, how did your results turn out?
Jake: 好像走那边吗
Jake: Oh, over there?
Lucia:他是RTF说你猜来着
Lucia: Was it RTF that you guessed?
Lucia:还是RTV说一点哦
Lucia: Or RTV, just a bit?
Jake:就我们就测了一遍哦OK
Jake: We just tested it once. Oh, okay.
Jake:对然后大多数都是一点
Jake: Yeah, most of it was a bit.
Lucia:大多数都是一点
Lucia: Most of it was a bit.
Jake:结论就是这样
Jake: That's the conclusion.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:所以你们最初的假设是什么呢
Lucia: So, what was your initial hypothesis?
Jake:我们就是就假设
Jake: We just assumed...
Jake:因为我们
Jake: Because we...
Lucia:假设
Lucia: Assumed?
Jake:稍微试了试
Jake: Tried a bit.
Jake:就是很多这种图哦
Jake: There were a lot of these kinds of pictures.
Jake:就给问给他了很多这种QA他都做不好
Jake: Gave him a lot of these QAs, and he couldn't do it well.
Jake:然后大概就搞一个
Jake: Then we kind of just made one.
Lucia:所以你们根据结论修改了自己的假设
Lucia: So, you adjusted your hypothesis based on the conclusion, right?
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:就是这就这这这就是一个单纯的测试
Jake: It was just a pure test.
Jake:这没有假设就是他是什么样
Jake: There was no hypothesis, it was just how it was.
Jake:我们repot一下
Jake: We just reported it.
Lucia:OK OK啊OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK. Ah, OK, OK.
Lucia:做研究
Lucia: Doing research...
Lucia:主要学会根据结论修改自己的假设
Lucia: The main thing is to learn to adjust your hypothesis based on the conclusion.
Jake:小米空调是吗
Jake: Xiaomi air conditioner, right?
Jake:米家
Jake: Mijia.
Jake:你们看到过小米的车吗
Jake: Have you guys seen Xiaomi's car?
Jake:实体师没见过没有
Jake: No one has seen the real thing, right?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:这个词是什么呀
Jake: What does this word mean?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Jake:对今天就是对今天就是测试测就是测试
Jake: Yes, today is just, yes today is a test, just a test
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Jake:就是就是
Jake: It's just, just
Jake:呃实现了一些
Jake: Uh, achieved some
Jake:也
Jake: Also
Jake:其实大部分都实现了
Jake: Actually, most of it has been achieved
Lucia:那小部分没实现想争取实现一下
Lucia: Then for the parts that haven't been achieved, we should try to achieve them
Jake: 小部分争取实现什么
Jake: What are we trying to achieve with the parts that haven't been done?
Jake:抽像火锅
Jake: Abstract hot pot
Lucia:火锅已经吃过了这条PASS吧
Lucia: We've already had hot pot, let's pass on this one
Jake:就是乱买一些食材
Jake: Just buying random ingredients
Jake:或者抽签决定是吃什么
Jake: Or we could draw lots to decide what to eat
Jake:猪脑啊
Jake: Pig brain
Jake:对所以就不怕挨打
Jake: Right, so we're not afraid of getting hit
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:唉是吧是吧
Jake: Yeah, right, right
Lucia:看来没被实现的目标都是有原因的
Lucia: Looks like there's a reason why some goals weren't achieved
Lucia:哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, yes
Lucia:测出来
Lucia: Test it out
Jake:猪脑
Jake: Pig brain
Jake:一般 吧对
Jake: It's average, right
Jake:一听就爱
Jake: Once you hear it, you love it
Jake:但是这个太油了
Jake: But it's too greasy
Jake:我吃一次就不行
Jake: I can't handle it after one time
Lucia:羊眼
Lucia: Sheep eyes
Jake:羊眼啊
Jake: Sheep eyes, huh
Jake:羊眼也有
Jake: There are sheep eyes too
Jake:羊眼没吃过
Jake: Haven't tried sheep eyes
Jake:呵
Jake: Heh
Jake:这能买到吗
Jake: Can you buy these?
Jake:北京北京哦
Jake: In Beijing, Beijing, oh
Jake:得菜市场买吧
Jake: Gotta buy them at the market
Nicous: 我说实话这种东西好像东北特别火吧
Nicous: Honestly, this kind of stuff is really popular in the northeast, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Jake:这是贴地上
Jake: This is to be stuck on the ground.
Lucia:那应该一会就找不到了吧
Lucia: Then it will be hard to find soon, right?
Jake:对会化掉
Jake: Yeah, it will dissolve.
Jake:院子里是有人吗
Jake: Is there someone in the yard?
Alice:顺丰快递
Alice: SF Express delivery.
Jake:查水表
Jake: Checking the water meter.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:出来压了
Jake: Came out to press it down.
Jake:是在外边压的更结实吗
Jake: Is it pressed more firmly outside?
Jake:外边气压
Jake: Outside air pressure.
Jake:外边气压更适合压花
Jake: Outside air pressure is better for pressing flowers.
Jake:干嘛呀
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:今天薄荷叶干啥呀
Jake: What are we doing with mint leaves today?
Tasha:薄荷叶哦
Tasha: Mint leaves, oh.
Tasha:到了
Tasha: They arrived.
Jake:到了在哪呢
Jake: They arrived? Where are they?
Jake:今天做什么呀师傅
Jake: What are we doing today, master?
Jake:那您这是干嘛的呀
Jake: So what are you doing here?
Jake:就单烤地瓜
Jake: Just roasting sweet potatoes.
Lucia:我们是在外面烤
Lucia: We're roasting outside.
Lucia:那那个烤
Lucia: And that roasting.
Lucia:烤箱上不是烤肉炉上烤吗
Lucia: Isn't the oven on top of the grill for roasting?
Jake:嗯咱没炭炭咱就
Jake: Hmm, we don't have charcoal, so we...
Jake:不整碳了对咱就
Jake: Let's not use charcoal then, so we...
Lucia:给自己降低一点难度
Lucia: Let's make it a bit easier for ourselves.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia:有一种非常简约的美感
Lucia: It has a very minimalistic beauty.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:还要大一点更好看
Jake: It would look better if it were bigger.
Lucia:就是它可以无缝融入各种
Lucia: It can seamlessly blend into various...
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:这个
Jake: This.
Jake:要当道具吗
Jake: Should this be used as a prop?
Jake:这个
Jake: This.
Jake:好那为什么还得剪啊
Jake: Okay, then why still cut it?
Jake:哈哈哈薄荷
Jake: Hahaha, mint.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh my.
Jake:我看看啊
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake:有的有 有
Jake: There are some, there are.
Jake:give give it up
Jake: give give it up
Jake:有电吗你们还嚯
Jake: Do you guys have power?
Jake:呵呵没有
Jake: Haha, no.
Jake:你们两位都没有
Jake: Neither of you have it.
Shure: sorry就满了
Shure: Sorry, it's full.
Jake:不能你插电了吗
Jake: Couldn't be. Did you plug it in?
Shure: 我插了
Shure: I did.
Jake:那你看看怎么回事
Jake: Then check what's wrong.
Jake:sorry应该没那么快就满了
Jake: Sorry, it shouldn't be full so quickly.
Jake:你是
Jake: Are you...
Jake:你看看手机
Jake: Check your phone.
Jake:你应该删了
Jake: You should delete it.
Jake:你看一看怎么回事
Jake: Check what's going on.
Jake:没插上没摁
Jake: It's not plugged in, didn't press it.
Jake:那就不知道了
Jake: Then I don't know.
Jake:那没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:没关系你刚刚损失了点啥呀
Jake: It's okay, what did you just lose?
Shure: 我们俩唠嗑
Shure: We were just chatting.
Jake:那也行吧
Jake: That works too.
Jake:那是不是还是再重弹一遍
Jake: Should we play it again?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Jake:房间时候亮着吗
Jake: Was the room lit up?
Jake:也不知道
Jake: Don't know.
Jake:回头再说吧
Jake: We'll talk about it later.
Jake:反正没注意
Jake: Anyway, didn't notice.
Jake:好嘞下回
Jake: Alright, next time.
Jake:就是再说一遍
Jake: Just say it again.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 太引人入胜
Shure: Too captivating.
Jake:那得再录一遍
Jake: Then we need to record it again.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 就是把你们全知道
Shure: Just so you all know.
Shure: 我去看过
Shure: I've seen it.
Shure: 懂吗才能听这些
Shure: You need to understand to listen to these.
Jake:哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Jake:做狗
Jake: Be a dog.
Jake:哎你也没电了
Jake: Hey, you're out of power too.
Jake:你没电了
Jake: You're out of battery.
Alice:我线呢
Alice: Where's my cable?
Jake:在这吗找一找
Jake: Is it here? Look around.